[Music]
closing in on the first preseason
football games the season is the LEF koe
man and the freshly cut freshly trimmed
freshly out of the barbershop chair
David Ingeborg we had about a 25 minute
conversation before the podcast started
about when you go to a barber shop but
you don't get the guy you want right
it's it's this barbers listen this
podcast to you know I have no idea
because in his barber shop he's just
playing music videos all day which i
think is a cool move nice just like on
the TV's around so you don't have to
like watch you don't have to like get
sucked into an episode of TV show and
then you get called to the barber chair
and you can't keep watching it I hate
when they're showing like Law & Order or
something in a barber shop then you get
all sucks he's like I think this was a
murder and they're like David and you're
like no I don't know who the killer was
no it's this guy who's so nice and he
waves to me and I walk by with my baby
in the stroller and and so I got a few
haircuts from him when he started the
shop and now it's a couple years later
he's hired new people but I don't know
them I don't have trust built up yeah
but I show up I want to support the guy
I want to support his store so now I'm
going to this young guy and I've told
David I said well why don't you just
wait and he's like bro and you got a
baby you can't wait yeah I had make the
chair I have 30 minute windows to get
everything done that I need to get done
and it's like okay I have a haircut I
can I'm gonna run and get a haircut I
don't have time to like sit behind three
guys and wait I I set up an appointment
with Thiago watsu comma that's your guy
it's a woman okay it's a woman and she
just got back from Japan so now I can
get a haircut
nice yeah but I yeah I could do it
online how long do you go between
haircuts um what about like I'm a I'm a
three and a half week guy Wow
I've always wanted to be a
two-and-a-half week guy okay because you
have to worry about things you're on
camera are you like yeah that's that's
so you have to worry I'm a producer I'm
but if I look at myself when everyone
looks in the self in the mirror and they
go I need a haircut that hits me about
four weeks and four and a half is what
I'm like I look ridiculous when I can
rub the back of my hair and then yank
the hair with my fingers that was way
too
that's how short your hair normally is
yeah no no I'm saying like if if I can
like just you know you run your fingers
through the back here
and you can actually like pull things
early that I've waited too long yeah no
I like a little bit of hair wait I just
I think the whole barbershop thing is so
funny so like when you get the mirror
and he shows it to you oh another
problem is that you're watching it the
whole time here's another problem
there wasn't a timer you're like bro I
don't want that you've never seen me
wear glasses I'm a contacts guy at work
right but on weekends I'm often just
like wrong glasses I was just like I'm
wearing sandals frames I'm wearing
probably athletic shorts and like a
t-shirt from a company I used to work or
or a shirt that says Tom's basketball
camp 2004 yeah like the 5k that I didn't
even go to yes that's what I'm rocking
so I take my glasses walking around the
city with blind no I'm just in the hair
in the in the haircut chair cuz I have
to take them off cuz he's cutting around
my ears so I'm taking off so I'm
basically seeing a very blurry version
of myself and so you really have a big
reveal I have terrible eyes I definitely
cannot draw it wear contacts
I do but like for the barber shop
sometimes I don't know I'm gonna get a
haircut I just I run out because I need
to do it oh [ __ ] I'm wearing my glasses
again so then you come home you put your
glasses on you go what the hell just
happened Mon in the barber shop and the
guys looking at me like what do you
think and I'm like I don't yeah thank
you here's your $20 I gotta go that's
$20 haircut what am I going playing
about I remember when I first moved to
New York because the thing is when you
move you don't have your guy when I was
in Louisville I had my guy when I was in
abrasca I had my lady and then that's
the most stressful thing about moving to
a new city who's your dentist now like
where do you go for this that this then
I remember I wanted this barbershop and
to sit down the conversations good I
remember in my head I'm like you got
your guy and then he spun me around and
the bottom half of my hair was missing
it in the back of my head and he started
it so high and I was like bro what the
[ __ ] and he was like god this is a look
and I was like oh you're definitely not
the guy he's like what do you mean when
they're trying to defend haircuts based
on like current trends that you're
unaware of you're like I really have to
go really precise 60th on the east side
has a different style a lot of stuff
going on preseason football's gonna be
starting Thursday we are in this weird
awesome / awful combination of whoa
and damn it and that's what I'm gonna
call it is we're in the stage where guys
are getting injured in practice that's
the word not even getting injured in
preseason games they're not even getting
injured in regular season games so
Robert Quinn for the for the Cowboys
breaks his hand the entire Buffalo Bills
offensive line part of the reason why I
was expecting them to like make a run
this year
Mitch Morris has like his fourth
concussion last five years all the rest
of their offensive linemen are going
down
they got Russell Bodine in who I was
texting with Warren Sharpe is like
Warren sharps least favorite player of
all time like all these great plans and
I think about all these podcasts that
have come out over the last few weeks
from everybody division previews and
picking winners it all goes away because
like you start losing key guys like the
Bengals when AJ Green went down it's all
[ __ ] different wasn't this Warren
sharps big thing he was talking in your
podcast a couple of weeks ago you were
asking about overs and unders and he's
like look if you want a bet on
somebody's over wait until the
millisecond before their first game
because this stuff happens you're like
oh yeah I'm kind of bullish on the
angles over oh wait they just lost which
is which is why he said and you know
what I totally forgot that advice if
you're gonna bet unders to it now yeah
because the unders only gonna get better
no team's gonna like suddenly everybody
has grown a third leg to be super
healthy no it's they're only gonna get
less healthy so it's just that sad part
of the year I feel always bad for the
athletes themselves because they never
get to go out there but then also you
know it just it feels like you lose them
to nothing ya know so that's happening
but the preseason games start Thursday
night one guy that's gonna be back in
preseason shout-out to the homie Matt
Simms signed to the Falcons I still I
still love that guy [ __ ] his brother but
Matt I'm just kidding but I'm happy for
Matt and like from a football
perspective it works into a great spot
Matt Schaub looked awful in the hall of
fame game other guy gets turf toe and
that could last for like months and he's
the only one there and I'm just telling
you man like I I experienced what it's
like through that family to possibly be
told that
you're never gonna play in the NFL again
mmm and to format to go out there and
start a camp and we're working with kids
and then to get that phone call go we
want you to come down like I can't it's
like being born again it's like when you
hear people that die on the operating
table they come back they're like yeah
like Matt's coming back and like I was
like I just as a human that has to be so
cool do you you know I love those guys
the the Kurt Warner is this point you
know the the Jim Tomsula czar the world
sure yes you get that phone call and you
I'm back in the action baby I'm back in
the game like Bruce Arians was talking
about about how he you know he tried to
play golf a lot in his year off mm-hmm
and he realized he doesn't like golf and
he doesn't like his friends that much
and he just once this is what he does
and it's an identity thing these guys go
through it but I was super happy for
Matt so I wanted to give him some love
on here a lot of people hit me up about
the Baker Mayfield chunk and how that is
should impact my ranking shotgunning is
not the same as chugging did you see it
I saw that the shotgun yeah I just want
to say that I lived in Nebraska so I've
been to parties and barns so I was like
outdoors I've been with people that are
on eclis wearing overalls with nothing
underneath the fits little part look and
with but like that's just what they wear
on Tuesday and spittin I have seen
people bite into a beer can to make a
hole mm-hmm I've never seen the
quarterback of an NFL team do it and I
just want to say was one of the most
impressive things I've ever seen to tear
through a beer can the timing and all
that whatever yeah to just rip it like
I'm always does anyone have a key does
anyone have a pen I'm a big fan of the
fence post fence you just the problem is
though then then you're going down yeah
but like you just it's it's gonna get
sudsy everywhere anyway one I turned
into like a dad really quick I was like
baking your teeth good [ __ ] gums like I
got but I thought that was unbelievable
it was but again it should not affect
your chugging rankings because you're
getting a beer has nothing to do it's
these are apples and oranges yes they
both have to do with beer but like if he
played really well in beer pong in a
viral video would you say he's gonna be
a better chugger not necessarily oh
they're just beer related skills they're
not one that doesn't train
it would improve him in my tailgate with
a friend ring absolutely because that's
relevant yes because then I know if he's
that resourceful open a beer can with a
teeth what else is he gonna do do you
open beer bottles anyway interestingly
like a lighter a lighter is good yeah or
I'm really good at ruining the ends of
people's coffee tables that's the thing
yet so that you have to be in a very
specific place like some bar where
people do we're an air B&B
no no someplace that I it's they're not
gonna notice but like I don't wanna be
like and then like Timmy's mom walks in
I'm like sorry the other way that I like
is the you fold up a piece of paper like
eight or ten times in a row until it
basically resembles a lighter and then
you can know yeah yeah that's a nice one
man
I'm more of a tequila guy so I'm not
really doing beers but I just thought
Baker and and the whole energy of
Cleveland right now like I'm seeing the
reports that there's this buzz in the
locker room that Kareem hunt has been so
impressive that they're like holy crap
we get him back in week ten and it's
like they're gonna get this second surge
in like all and just the fact that you
have a quarterback with a mustache like
that on the screen
wearing a Lindor jersey biting into a
beer can and chugging it that is
literally how you get the entire city
rallied around Oh 100% and I do like
when guys go move to a city that they're
not from and then just embrace all the
other sports teams right like the
Tennessee Titans in embracing the
Nashville Predators right offensive line
shows up Boston is very good about this
Tom Brady's always at the Red Sox LeBron
did it a ton when he was with the Cavs
to the same Indians team it's like you
know LeBron is two or less he was that
the Phillies came right but you got to
see it and I think I genuinely think
that Baker may feel has become a big
Cleveland Indians fan and I dig that I
dig it too yeah but he looks like every
guy that I've ever met in Cleveland
write a mustache in the Lindo or Jersey
yeah all of them look the same we are
gonna have an interview a little bit
later with Vince Carter it's gonna be
our final interview from Tom
and we talked about if he was gonna go
to the Hall of Fame what dunk would be
played at a ceremony what it was like
seeing the team that he was on all those
years and the Toronto Raptors finally
win one and he's not a part of it I
talked to him what it's like being 44
was it it's 42
I heard he's the same age as a teammates
dad he's yeah he's like a month or two
older than Trey Young's dad that's
insight so Trey Young's is 20 it's his
second year in the league and he's 20
Vince is 42 and is you know his dad is
like 41 and a half or something but the
other thing that I think I think you
guys will appreciate is Vince Carter is
an enormous Tampa Bay Buccaneers fan
yeah and we spent like half the
interview talking about Simeon rice
Warren Sapp and Ronde Barber you know I
love talking to athletes about the thing
that they're not allowed to talk about
very often right Vince Carter there ask
him hey how about that that mm dunk
contest no you Doug did you know that
Kenny Smith was saying it's over right
like we're doing this he's had that
conversation you're like hey what's up
with Warren Sapp and he's like oh he's
like sat up in his chair and was like I
love the Bucs bro like I go to all the
games and ball off I can I'm like that's
amazing you know what cuz people ask you
all the time but like how to get into
sports media yeah that is one concrete
piece of advice I can give you is find
out something random about an athlete
and ask them about that you'll get a
very interesting sound but they light up
which is why like when you ask Bill
Belichick about Tom Brady he doesn't
want to answer you but if you ask him
about some lacrosse player from the 90s
he'll talk your ear off and then you get
an interview with Bill Belichick and and
then maybe you could get something off
of that and you can like you could
parlay that into something yes always
talk about what people kind of want to
talk about the hardest thing is figuring
out what hasn't been asked yet mm-hmm
because I think sometimes research can
be crippling because it takes you down
these paths that so many people have
already gone down and then it's like
okay what town did he grow up in okay
well what do people in that town like
right you know I mean you have to like
generalize it in a way to kind of go
okay well if you grew up in this area
Florida who did he root for growing up
and and I love making athletes remember
that they're fans yes that's the coolest
thing yeah it's the second wave of
internet web you know you can google
like okay what's a qualm berkeley like
you're gonna find his wiki page yeah I
find is he
vn profile you're gonna find all these
interviews that he's done recently but
if you can go deep and you can find
something about him or his past or
something he was a fan of or what poster
was on his wall as a kid yeah you build
from that I we need to get into hard
knocks let's do it
so this was in my mind the most height
hard knocks in a very long time and at
every reason to Raiders the elements are
there not only is it the Raiders we're
getting Jon Gruden miked up we're
getting a brand-new GN that came from
television we're getting the what is
gonna be how the hell did they land in
Tonio brown like i was so excited to see
what the mustache and maybe they have
phone calls they went through and may
och in the draft and taking Cleveland
Pharrell and no one even thought about
it or we're gonna get Josh Jacobs in the
story of him growing up in the car and
moving to Vegas and the character that's
Mark Davis fountas perfect incognito and
they're just coming through the door
like that guy yeah and and I went I went
this is incredible
and I gotta say that the first episode
was a little disappointing okay except
for one thing
oh go ahead it's the Jonathan Abram show
yeah [ __ ] rookie our rookie Jonathan
Abram is the star of hard knocks
everybody should bow down and if you're
annoyed by him I will fight you and that
goes to Pat McAfee who texted me that
he's a little bit annoyed by him Pat I
know you got a lot of jobs I'm gonna go
to one of them I'm gonna kick your ass
probably we were talking downstairs this
is the new HBO model is the first
episode of a season is the Game of
Thrones episode right we're not anything
quite happens but you're sowing the
seeds for things to happen later on in
the season but my issue is every first
episode of hard knocks takes you to
where we are in the current day sure
usually it's like who was it last year
you talked about with the Browns Browns
dananananana
you know what I mean and it's it took me
to draft day and yeah explain to me who
Baker Mayfield was and explain to me who
John Dorsey was and it
it went it showed a clip of like Hugh
Jackson like it would be like Hugh
Jackson walking down the hall I'd be
like good to see you wouldn't be like
Hugh Jackson has been the head coach for
two seasons we got nothing
I think though it went through the John
facendo which I thought was great yeah
playing the old the autumn wind as a
pirate and inputting it just as soon as
I heard that voice I was like hahahaha
what a wind is a Raider put into the
music but the first thing we got to was
a Antonio bat on the brown on the field
yeah a lot of footwork and I said this
to you downstairs every single shot
seemed to have been gained over the last
week
you're a producer mm-hmm you know that
when you're sitting there to do a story
you have an arc and you're gonna have
episode 1 episode 2 in episode 3 episode
1 felt like an episode 3 to me there was
no character building
we like they put Jonathan Abram through
out 80% of that show they never said
they never showed Jonathan Abram at
college they never showed him like like
he was just a rookie and the only reason
we knew his work he's because he's
pushing $500 in a snack the only person
we actually got like background b-roll
on was Antonio Brown scoring touchdowns
and I was like we all have seen this
yeah I did find that it was I thought it
was an interesting directorial choice
and I kind of disagree like from a
producer standpoint I think people that
are tuning into this show they know who
Jon Gruden is they know what's going on
with the Raiders they they went straight
in in media stressed they went in the
middle of things they just went here
let's just get to practice because we
all know that Jon Gruden was on TV for
10 years then we all know that he won
the Super Bowl in 2002 we know this
stuff let's just get to practice and
less I was there I'd go I'd go look this
hard-knocks the reason that the Adam
left goes the world liked it so much is
because it's really for the common fan
and the people that watch HBO but don't
pay attention to the NFL every day and
so I love the story arcs that they
normally do and we didn't you know we
didn't we didn't get the 4 a.m. alarm
clock we didn't get all that stuff isn't
this the new wave of media though just
get right into it yeah you're just
there's you don't want to waste any time
because people's eyeballs like they're
the real estate that we're looking at is
so precious because people are watching
this thing while go
and the thing that I would argue through
that is if you are the storytelling
platform of hard knocks and HBO be the
premium be the be the group that's not
trying to keep up you're not roto world
you're not pro football talk I I don't
need like also thank God Ronald Ollie's
off the show like to all the last chance
use superfans which I found none of you
like last chance you was a great show
but nobody's sitting there with Ronald
Lally like he's in a kpop band but that
storyline get that [ __ ] out of here yeah
I named 20 things earlier I do not care
about last chance you I mean was it was
like that that it was it was like a the
most interesting Ronald Ollie moment was
the clip from yes last chance you just
rolling across the field like I was like
that's amazing give me Maura that stuff
but I I thought overall kind of going
through the entire show I do need more
Gruden yeah and I will say before I get
to all the great Abram you're back not
good I don't either but I had a one they
had me doing Gruden lines for gridiron
Heights huh and then halfway through the
Dennis was like your accidents
completely changed I go I lost it it's
never coming back I'm not gonna go to do
it but he had a few that I thought were
great one where he was like this isn't
the Gator Bowl this isn't the Peach Bowl
this is the Bluebonnet Bowl his whole
nightmare speech was awesome not here to
give dreams I'm so [ __ ] good the fact
that he's in there and he talked about
no rookie hazing and they just showed
Richie incognito like two seconds before
I thought was good yeah and he he has
these things where he gives that look
but he had that one where he goes we
lead the league and effort men it
doesn't take talent doesn't take Talent
it's a decision that you make and I was
like oh that was really good I don't
know if this is on your list but he also
had like those four rules
he's like be on time bust your ass there
was like two more rules that were like
yeah trihard yeah it was like don't be
an idiot yeah he was common sense pretty
simple I really like that I was like
those are the four rules that Jon Gruden
lives by like the kind of works in
almost any field bill Romanowski is just
like walking around the sidelines and
stuff but the other Gruden lines that I
really liked was he leans in a derrick
karr and he goes be careful of a broom
be careful
24:00 like giving him notes like a
abrams kind of crazy at that one
practice yeah I loved that practice
we're getting into gamer in a second but
he also goes he had one line where he's
looking at Antonio Brown he goes amen he
goes can you slow down and Antonio Brown
was like sometimes you got to bring the
juice and he walked away and Gruden
looked at his assistant goes when he's
out her out here he elevates everybody
and I was like like I want Gruden to be
obsessed with a bee yeah
like I wanted to be obsessed with Abram
like I want Gruden to have favorites
because I know he plays favorites so
it's fun to know who his favorites are
and in the last one I liked when they
were doing the omage to John Madden with
the seven man sledge yes and he goes
this ain't no college two-point stance
[ __ ] session and I was like those
words combined into a sentence are
[ __ ] awesome I want to have like a
John Gurdon sound board for the rest of
the year so just like any time you say
like like like a lukewarm take I can be
like this ain't no two points sound by
you know like [ __ ] yeah um the a
B foot storyline I know that Ian
Rapoport is claiming it like his own
news story I'm gonna give credit to the
old homie Sims for this cryogenic
chamber have you ever been in a
cryogenic chamber no so I have and I did
the gloves and they put very thick socks
on you and you go in there and you wear
shorts and so like a lot of your
extremities are covered and your head
obviously doesn't go in and it's that
standing tube and if the temperature
gets to like minus 280 or whatever the
degrees is and apparently Antonio Brown
in went in barefoot and has frostbite on
his feet and as we saw on Hard Knocks
can't control himself from going a
hundred miles an hour and then goes the
doctor goes my feet hurt and the doctor
gross I told you not to run a hundred
miles an hour and I just know that as
someone who nicknamed himself Tony
toe-tap and someone that we always
credit about being able to get his feet
down I don't know if you know anyone
that has had frostbite serious frostbite
I was leader up in Boston yes I was
talking to my dad last night my dad does
air conditioning refrigeration he's
handled a lot of freon
he's gotten frostbite in his fingertips
before he but you know what happens when
it gets cold now he can't feel the tip
of his fingers right what if Antonio
browning fill in the bottom of foot
David like how is that impacting routes
how is that impacting cuts that was that
impacting putting your feet down the
sidelines like I know that this is I'm
extrapolating my dad
- Antonio Brown but if Antonio Brown is
on his feet and the speed of his feet is
everything and and you could tell when
he starts saying quotes on that show
about I got to do this for my livelihood
which means he's pushing through pain
right now we're having pain and he's not
running 80 routes in a game he's
practicing III and I'm looking - all the
money they gave a Antonio Brown and
right now I'm going this first season
might be in deep deep trouble for the
for the Raiders what if we go the other
way what if having numbness in the
bottom of your feet is like a superpower
and he can just like run faster and it
like he doesn't even feel the pounding
and he just comes back after the game
and his he takes his cleats off and
pools of blood come out and can't even
feel it yeah sure I mean I'm just
speculating here like if you're
speculating of Koenig oh the superhero
narrative III what what if his entire
body can't feel anything
yeah he's indestructible that's like
that character of the movie kick-ass
right like it like he couldn't feel pain
so he was like you just fight with
burglars until they got tired and so
much so the worst thing is Antonio
Browns feet are falling apart and it
could end his career the the other part
is he's indestructible and could be a
superhero I don't know I'm just saying
this just saying is like anything could
happen it's tuned in Hard Knocks I see
those I think that's uh that's an
interesting take on it but it's what I'm
here for I just know that if I signed
like 40 million guaranteed to a wide
receiver and he showed up with that
picture of his feet I'm freaking out
let's talk about our man Jonathan Abram
you thought him coming with the food and
the candy is the best way to get
introduced as a football player in any
show yeah well so as you know when I'd
be hiding it out more than whenever I'm
watching a reality show I pay a lot of
attention to the intros of new
characters there's foreshadowing right
it's a lot of foreshadow I mean it's a
lot of just doing as much work with
showing not telling right so when you
are watching I don't know
let's say like a real housewives show
and the first time we see some new
housewife that's on the show and she's
got like a jug of wine in her hand and
she's saying like bring me my socks and
you're like okay now I know exactly who
you are in three seconds so in five
seconds we saw Jonathan Abram going
through the parking lot doing his duty
you know he's but like complaining about
it calling other players bougie some of
the they want me to go to Target not
Walmart cuz they're bougie the candy
falls all over the parking lot he's like
dammit he just picks it right back up he
doesn't ask somebody else to help him I
was like we got a lot of Jonathan Abram
character development in five seconds I
just thought it was really well done
really well chosen as an introduction to
clearly someone that's gonna be an
important character in the show this is
me sharing the truth I was so proud in
that moment he's your guy when he went
and when they started show exactly what
you're saying I go they're giving him
the rookie showing up to camp like
montage yes that's what I've always
wanted and I felt like a proud dad what
I did not expect was for him to be like
80% of the episode it was amazing yeah I
mean a lot of Abram he comes in beyond
the whole he goes horseback riding with
Cleland Ferrell talking about how he
owns Tour Hort two horses he does the
wayon Brothers theme song and then he
catches a grape in his mouth which you
know isn't important I didn't even see
that
oh yeah Cleveland like tosses him a
grape I miss that oh yeah but that eased
to an Old Town Road news as they put
that as the background music now he's
the executive producer of all the music
supervisor of hard knocks now then he's
getting yelled at in the very next scene
for hitting people in practice I'm
laughing because I do pay attention to
every news story and all the news
stories coming out of Raiders camps our
coaches and players love his intensity
that was the first practice so obviously
it's calm down but when I went online
there's a lot of hate for for Jonathan
Abram right now people saying that like
he's reckless mama and I'm like he's not
any of these things first of all good to
be polarizing you don't want to be a
guess right if no one was tweeting about
him that would be worse than if some
people liked him some people hated him I
wanted to get your take though that
conversation he has with Gruden because
you've been on a lot more sidelines a
lot more locker room
you know Jon Gruden is saying the thing
that he has to say which is like hey
don't [ __ ] with my guys you know we're
not wearing pads yet we're wearing
shorts don't lay people out and you know
you could tell Abram had a little smirk
on his face like I didn't touch him it
you know like he was doing that thing in
your mind was Gruden saying the things
he needed to say because he's a coach
but in the back of his head he's like I
[ __ ] love this guy I love how hard he
plays there was one moment where
Cruden's talking to Tahir Whitehead and
whiteheads go we need to protect each
other we can't be doing this and Vaughn
tez perfect leans in and there's no
audio but he just goes kind of like I
[ __ ] like it kosher again and the
thing is is I think Gruden has probably
been in his ear for two months since
mini camp being like I need you to bring
that I need you to bring it on easy to
bring it and I think Gruden was serious
though I think Gruden's like you're
you're knocking guys to the ground and
the one thing I know is the NFL coach is
more than anything hate when people are
on the ground in practice because that's
what leg injuries happen sure so when
Luke Wilson goes to the ground if the
wide receiver trips over him you might
lose Tyrell Williams for the year right
so I do think that was serious but it's
kind of like if you had a dog and every
time you you had a wrestling match and
then one time you gave it and said don't
wrestle me with this time and the dogs
like but we wrestle every move yeah
that's what it seemed like to me and
then Gruden did exactly what he had to
do which was go up to the wide receiver
afterwards and go I talked to him we're
all good but I'm also positive that
crude and probably once the coach staff
Torrance were like I love it
mm-hmm like that's the kind of [ __ ] that
I love but also don't forget this ever
Gruden as an offensive guy he he
appreciates angry defenders but in the
end if you mess with his offense right
he's got a problem right because that's
his baby so I do think it was serious I
just think he's been hyping up Abram for
the last like two three months and I was
like bro I'm giving you exactly what you
wanted right and look there we're
recording this on a Wednesday they're
practicing against the Rams today if you
don't think that Abram is gonna be
jaalin at Brandon cooks and Ja land at
Robert woods that you don't think he's
gonna be going - Robert - Brandon cooks
and going I saw you get concussed in the
I'm gonna do that to you today like
remember Jonathan Abram said on this
podcast he's a researcher so his [ __ ]
talk is developed and I I think now the
whole you're gonna I think my prediction
is for hard knocks is you're gonna see
the same teammates that were like you
know chill out be like you that's who
you hit like I think it's gonna turn can
we ask the 33% to help out our man
Jonathan Abram by doing research like if
you went to high school with some guy
that he's playing this weakling give him
some inside info like oh is his
girlfriend in 8th grade was named blah
blah blah it's due to things
let's go if you see be diya people going
after Jonathan Abram I don't want you to
insult them I don't want you to get
angry I don't they hate breeds hate but
I want you to go I just want you to say
I love and will always love Jonathan
Abram hashtag 33% and and to the other
point well well I think this is a good
regular-season thing every time the
Raiders play somebody we we have the the
listeners research some stuff on the
receivers of the other team I'll hit up
Abram and go here are the ones that were
used here's what the Internet has
provided and then what I would love this
is we're producing live on the show
right now
on Mondays I'll hit them up be like did
you use any of them and if you did what
were their reactions and then if we
catch it on miked up at some oh my god
now we're talking now we got something
yeah I heard they used to cheat trade
baloney sandwiches for hostess yeah I
heard you got a c-minus in chemistry and
a lot of people got upset that Jonathan
Abram was talking about Derek cars money
yeah and that they thought Derek Carr
was weirded out by it I'm just gonna say
that I thought that Derek Carr was
playing that the cameras the entire time
I liked Derek Carr he came across the
cool dad okay you know why you loved him
cuz he came home was cool he just seemed
like he always knew where the camera was
yes hypermedia trained salmon or Salman
do I say what do I say I say salmon
salmon I mean no he's a salmon I meant
yeah
but for Abram to have that and the
gelding he made the credit roll to and
he went up to G easy the white rapper
and said I heard you and I knew you were
black like I I really felt like a proud
dad like and then I went online I typed
in Jonathan
hard-knocks it was like all these people
hating and I was like I will fight all
of you yeah I'm so happy for him
guy fieri made an appearance and Richie
incognito saying that KY Fieri's my guy
is like the least surprising thing I've
ever heard of my entire life that's
gonna be a show at some point right what
did you think about Guy Fieri having to
stand in the fan section but gez was out
on the field that's an interesting one
because he was talking about like I've
cooked for these or I want to cook guys
and I said to you downstairs it's like
that moment when Drake couldn't get into
the Miami Heat yeah the room I was I
kind of was like yo guy you like one
thing I'm fascinated by and this is not
just sports with actors it's the the
tears of celebrities that we have in our
life right like I feel like Tom Hanks
can just show up on any movie set and
they're like oh you're Tom Hanks you can
just like stay the director if you want
that welcome we're glad to have you
whereas I don't know if Ansel Elgort
shows up on a movie set they'd be like
yeah you're really good but like what
are you doing here man right there's
tears well I always I think of this guy
fieri is someone that is so such a
distinct looking human that people
naturally go oh [ __ ] I liked that guy
I'm gonna go talk to him but then what
the hell do you talk to Guy Fieri about
cooking lately yeah how's the donkey
sauce kickin that's that's what I'm
saying before you have to be prepped for
that moment you have to find out that
he's actually like really into
Manchester United or something you've
been asking about that yeah but it was I
just they were just standing there they
didn't know what to say they got like I
don't what do you say to Guy Fieri where
do you a lot of Chinese trying who's
your barber you have to wait in line he
cuts his own hair probably but I I said
this to downstairs that on incognito and
Antonio Brown was the watercooler
of generic NFL conversation I do like
this so like Antonio Brown comes over
and in Canas like hey welcome to team
new guy and it turns like yo what's
going on and Incognito's like yeah man
you know just got a first season and a
B's like yo y'all are big up front any
kind needs to go we're biggest [ __ ] up
front they're like hahaha
and Tony Brown's like you're gonna make
some holes man Ron OH
Holsey later and it's like what'd you do
this weekend oh man nothing
yo sometimes nothing's the best thing
absolutely working hard or hardly work
oh man and that was just like the NFL
version at their shop time it was just
incognito and a B just being like man
you're gonna open up some holes big
enough for you to run through that's so
fun yeah when you find out that like
certain really really famous people are
best friends and then I wonder like what
do they talk about you know like what
what is I can't even think of a good
example but like to to really famous
athlete like LeBron and Dwayne Wade are
best buds right when they're out are
they like man shooting threes is fun
yeah sure sure is sure do I really like
throwing layups you know in the layup
line but I thought I thought overall it
was okay it's just good to have it back
in our life as soon as you hear there is
no whining in football football is back
in wine country I was like so back baby
did you catch that did not that was Liev
Schreiber just like at his Lea Venus Lea
vest and it just made me so happy I was
like this show just knows what it is
it's aware of what people want from it
and it delivers those things you know
gave me gave me guys on horses it gave
you a lot of footwork a lot of a lot of
good b-roll those strings
[Applause]
I need it it's 3:30 a.m. mm-hmm
and Jon Gruden is getting on his second
coffee like I just I didn't I
I want the duh I want the ride to work
David
I want the drive I want the alarm clock
I want the dark office I want the one
silhouette light
I want mike Mayock at the draft board
going mike Mayock liked Cleland Farrell
but nobody else did like I ain't
marrying his face and his ass what am I
gonna do I need Marc Davis getting a
haircut mm-hmm these are I need Davis
getting here goes to the same guys mean
$20 a haircut in Harlem just realizing
right now that I didn't like it as much
as I thought I did and I'm the only
reason I like this because Jonathan
Abram is my guy let's do Vince Carter
now when we come back things are
changing in Cleveland there's a battle
brewing in Dallas right now that I don't
think is gonna end anytime soon
and we need to update you on the biggest
mmm man-to-man combat known the Bears
kicking battle that's all coming up but
first let's check in with Vince Carter I
am here with a legend one of the
greatest athletes the universe has ever
seen and I will say that you are looking
very felt here on the golf course it's
gone well covered but comfortable I am
gonna be so burned and you're gotta keep
team keep the the I don't know walnut
color I don't know I think you just
finished right yeah see you're the first
person I'm talking to actually finished
actually we had tomorrow okay how'd you
do though we did okay we did okay
it's one of those you slow start going
what was your best shot of the day I had
a birdie putt to say thanks man
I had a birdie putt couple birdie putts
out here a couple of great drives couple
300 Drive so it worked out you're going
into what year now in the NBA this will
be year 22 well like I'm 33 all right
there you go but what is that like to
come out of your mouth when you hear I'm
one with it now if you were to ask me
this
maybe five years ago it was there's a
little different like you know you had
guys saying hey you know I had your
poster on my wall but yet we're about to
compete in a bathroom yeah personal
basketball game I'm one with it now so
but it's just cool I'm blessed and
thankful that I'm still able to receive
phone calls at at this age you know so I
think the coolest thing is too is that
some guys we go okay man we get it yeah
it's been enough for you you're playing
all these different teams you're the
stories that you're gonna tell for all
the different guys that you've played
with over this time is like yeah you're
also at an age where you're gonna
appreciate it if you were younger you
like no so the wisdoms gonna be just
absolutely I mean it's great to kind of
get the opportunity to play in different
cities and different with different guys
and and you know different franchises
and you kind of get to see no doubt
difference and yes but you know I think
one more year of this and you know I'm
gonna move on to something else
if we're in ducting Vince Carter to the
Hall of Fame and we can only put in one
dunk I'll let you I'll let them pick for
me it's between dunk contest which is
wild because that's how much you killed
it and then the French guy you ever see
the only problem is they wouldn't be
able to ever show the video because it's
the Olympics it's like the Olympics in
the NBA so you'd have to pick if you
actually saw a video now if you showed a
picture maybe it's all about the yeah
it's all about the right to know the
rights to this and that's the soul stuff
my show is typically an NFL show okay
are you an NFL fan go bucs simple
Buccaneers family remember who was like
your guys growing up my staff is one of
my good friends
really jeremy coy who I'm sad to see go
is one of my really good friend out you
know so you know we go I go back Doug
Williams is that my former co-host was
Chris Sims were you down with Christian
oh yeah I mean he supported a mob you
know for sword-like Doug Williams you
know one of the og of our day this is
how much I carry overs here you know I
talked with him yeah so I love that
you're a fan fan yeah so I'm an Eagles
fan okay and let me just gave you our
DeSean Jackson I appreciate that very
much
yeah but I also think like early 2000s
our little playoff back and forth where
we'd knocked out Shaun King and then Ron
de Arbor yeah took my soul as a child
yeah yeah like what was your like
because a lot of people see you as an
athlete and you're kind of cool with
everything but when the Bucs won the
Super Bowl
where were you at the Raiders uh where
was it did you really take it every time
I was in Toronto so that was during this
season in Toronto I couldn't tell you
exactly but yeah oh for sure
you know if we're you know some hotel in
a ballroom yeah I was watching my guys
obviously because of the season is tough
unless it's in your city or you happen
to be in the city you know we don't get
a chance to go there unless it's an off
day and you know you take that flight
somewhere but I was definitely tuned in
why I mean look Sunday barber work done
all stop yeah did you burn up
I had a few I had a snap Jersey I have a
few now I have a couple of you know so I
last last summer I went over to training
camp yeah while they were there and I
did the last home preseason game before
I had to report to camp and I was out to
hang with the guys and Mike Evans and
DeSean and all was chatting up and
Jameis so it was it's cool you know like
I said that was really the first time
believe it or not being a book fan made
they knew it but it was my first time
actually being able to get down there to
practice my first time ever sitting
there being along the field with the
guys talking with him so it was cool I
mean and when they came when they were
in Atlanta I was there as well
yeah rooting for the books how much joy
did you have a real books fans oh I can
[ __ ] tell win and losing seasons like
even like you were growing up and they
had like those jerseys getting their ass
kicked all the time yeah when God
yeah absolutely yeah I had to have a
couple hats from back then I respected a
man it's great the joy that you felt for
the City of Toronto yeah to get this
title I tell you what in i'ma tell you
what was more especially I couldn't be
there for
games one and two family obligations
just to be there for games game five at
home and to be honored and addressed
with the crowd and then kind of Game six
being that calling the game yes seeing
them win was just insane
it's kind of awesome where the game is
right now yeah it's a special special it
is it is like I'm upset that I see like
the NBA contracts and I've well I want
to play for the youth yeah exactly even
ten years ago but I look at the NFL guys
like I had Todd Gurley on like a few
weeks ago and he was like man I just got
a 40 million dollar contract and those
are doing the NBA whose name I don't
even feel making me deal with me up yeah
it's it's just wild it's the way it is
man I mean just think this guy's making
40 million a year what are you year I
could sit here with Vince Carter all
freakin day all right here you go but no
I'll tell you what I think the one thing
about the NBA that's it's like you said
it's in a good place
we're seeing a lot of talented guys I
think the NBA would take off even more
if there was a little more parity I
think we're gonna get it now
I mean we're getting it with the twos
instead of the super team yet you know
because now it leaves you in a spot
where you like damn I'll know who's
gonna write instead of saying yeah going
system it felt like the error just ended
though didn't it yeah I mean it's a
pretty cool situation than that I tip my
hat to Golden State for being able to
put together a team like that and you
know we can we can be upset all we want
they didn't do anything illegal no and
they do grab those guys they got players
who are willing to come to their team
for a discount for a discount that's
when you know your culture is crazy next
coach is awesome we're gonna help me
back twenty nineteen twenty twenty bucks
season what what's what's the Vince
Carter outlook on the team Bruce Arians
now at the helm James coming back I
think this is kind of another fresh
start
that's they take another day but I like
where we are in what he stands for
no nonsense get our work done type of
guy so I think that's gonna rub off and
it's always good for a young to
and you know anytime you have a bunch of
young guys and you have a older coach
yeah and around old school code he's
cool I said exactly and I think that's
this great for our organization you know
we go as James goes in and for one you
know and that sound like you know you
think you would think I play football
all the time but you know our defense
will take care of yourself yes we've
been notorious yeah yeah so we've been
we've been good
it's just now when our office catches up
but we have talent we have the ability
oh so Mike Evans is top faster hips
absolutely so when you put the two
together you know we're making a play
off Chris Godwin was absolutely we don't
make a playoff push if you guys are out
there 33% and someone ever makes fun of
you for saying we or our just let them
know that Vince Carter when he talks
about the 10 Bay Bucs all day we we our
every day's being a fan is [ __ ] dope
yeah hey on top of that hey I'll put
let's say we in person on social media
we bucks bucks bucks all day I love that
shoutout to Eden making this happen
let's go
you see yeah appreciate you yeah yeah I
really want to watch a Tampa Bay game
now with Vince Carter sure I'm gonna see
if it's possible probably not but let's
go right with the Bears kicking battle
you said that you've actually look stuff
up yes is it can I read the information
for Monday I would love for you to read
the information you have so because I
have the information to Trump that
information as soon as I just want to
make sure you had different information
I do so Saturday apparently was amazing
between Panero and Elliott Frye for
those that don't realize the Bears
season ended on the double doink they
one of the best teams in football
to be honest I've done a lot of research
on the Bears and if they don't win this
year they're very much in trouble moving
into the future
I don't say that lightly they traded
multiple picks for Khalil Mack and they
don't really have a future and with
Khalil max salary they're not to be able
to be big players in free agency this is
a huge year for the Bears so they need
to make sure the kicking game is correct
any Panero Elliot Frey
Eddie Panero incredible college kicker
Elliot Frey Laura de Gators baby trying
to do it Saturday they were both in
we talked about a week ago when they
were kicking sixty orders against each
other
apparently Monday was really bad
Eliot Frey my guy went seven of nine but
missed from 45 and 43 your guy Panera
went six of nine missed from 39 44 and
53 prompting Matt Nagy to say they know
they've got to do better one of the
things I'm watching Thursday night of
all the preseason games Panthers Bears
if there was red zone all I'd want is
Elliott fried Panera I want to know
who's taking the first kick I want shots
of them on the sidelines like I hope
that Matt Nagy is such a baller that
it's third and five from the 30 and he
says I'm afraid we might get a first
down Pinero go kick it right like you
weren't ready to kick it too bad like I
hope that everything is geared around
the kicking so what do you have that I
didn't know about mr. Manero fan
yeah so I'm team Panero it's Panero
actually so they've got the NA so I I
went a little deep dive on their
instagrams oh man which is something
that's usually york yeah I went on
Elliot fries Instagram this man has
dozens of photos of him with his
girlfriend or fiance on beaches going on
ski trips going to ugly-sweater parties
for christmas this married a very fun
rounded out life and you know what I'm
sure you really enjoy it you go on my
man Eddie paneros Instagram page it is
nothing but football we're talking about
quotes about football tweets about
football videos of him kicking him in in
jerseys him you know like cheering on
his teammates it's nothing but football
I had to go all the way back to May 16th
2016 to find him in a beach chair and
anywhere on his Instagram now damn that
really makes me upset I know I know you
the guy that is exclusively focusing on
football now look Elliot Frye I'm sure
you have a wonderful girlfriend I'm sure
she you know you guys have a great
relationship
seems like you don't there's this one
photo where like they're on a beach and
you could see he's got like tan lines
for days like this man is like getting
outdoors and like living it up and I
love that for you I want that I want
Elliot Frey to have a good time on
weekends as much as possible because my
man
Eddie Panero is grinding on
the tariff would even yeah kick kills me
kills me you know I wanted I was hoping
that your time with Elliott Fry's
instagram page was just packed with
Pythagorean theorems there to measure
the shortest distance just like this
math whiz and I really I really hurts my
heart
mm-hmm I'm not gonna lie that you got
the super-focused football guy and I got
old Tanny McGee Elliott fry Danny tanner
I'm still feeling good about it you
should we're gonna find out I just which
so funny is I've talked about this book
before that was written by Michael Lewis
where I was talking about a bias and it
was one of the first chapters was about
the Houston Rockets and how they don't
believe in having private workouts
anymore hmm because why would I value
the 80 shots that you put up in front of
me over the like eight thousand shots
that I have charted so they found that
like someone could come and have like
one good workout and it would negatively
impact they would positively impact
their view of hating them that would
skew them I mean that's interesting for
the Rockets specifically because they
talked about Dwight Howard making like
20 free throws in a row in practice
every time it's just funny to me that
Elliott fry and Panero are probably
gonna kick hundreds of kicks for the
Bears but it's gonna come down to like
if Panero misses like a 47-yard or
against the Panthers on Thursday exactly
and Fri it's a 44 like they're gonna
base it off the one and really should
the Bears keep both kickers on roster
there's no way that a team can justify
to roster spots you throw maybe one on
the kit on the practice squad but you
can always just pick him back up
we've found that paneros better in early
game situations and Fries better late I
like what you're saying that like it's
gonna come down to one kick but in a way
it's not because like I feel that way
whenever I'm watching Game seven of any
sort of series and it's like oh my god
it's all gonna come down to this one
free throw well it's not because every
team had a chance to separate themselves
earlier in the series by the way
accumulating all the kicks from training
can thus far paneros kicking 84.8
Elliott fry is kicking 83 points I mean
it could not be tighter my man
Pinero though in 2017 went 17 for 18 and
you know playing in the SEC like there's
some like some legit rusher like 17 for
18 is no
man hey Nick you mind if you punched
that button that makes all the cool low
sounds come out cuz I've got a few for
the audience big offseason we're
flipping it around David I'm proposing
him to you and I want to hear your
reaction delighted by this first we're
starting off at Patriots camp hmm don't
look now but Jared Stidham rookie
quarterback his quote turning heads
people turn heads like I just I just
imagine that everyone the coaching staff
has a neck brace on yeah and it's a lot
of effort to turn the heads it's the
it's the tennis or ping-pong audience
just watching oh just looking yes that's
that's all I picture is just a whole
bunch of media guys just their heads
turning like I'm not even gonna read
this [ __ ] he's got good command he's
looked comfortable just the notion that
like any quarterback that's on the same
roster as Tom Brady who just signed an
extension is even relevant like I don't
I don't care about Jared Stidham until
three years from now of course when Tom
Brady's coming up and then like Jared
stidham's like okay are you the guy now
what I find really funny though is like
that Ponzi scheme mentality if we can
just keep rolling this over it's like
they take a fourth round draft pick of
Jared Stidham they're like if he plays
pretty well in pre-season we might be
able to flip it for a third-round pick
there we go now we got value it's like
what is that they keep doing it I know
I'm saying it's just this never-ending
cycle until one day like it all turns
out that the Patriots haven't liked to
have no draft picks left in 2028 well
the crazy thing to me always is these
teams they go and they trade for these
guys and they really don't get to meet
these guys first they don't even know
what they're about and I've always
believed the Patriots are the perfect
place to succeed they handle all of the
[ __ ] for you that you just have to
do your job sure and so going and
running and just following Tom Brady and
then playing in a preseason game and
looking good like the fact that like a
franchise like the Dolphins would be
like he'd be great with us mm-hmm like
no that's not how it works although
Jimmy Garoppolo like played awesome for
the Asians and the 49ers were like let
me just throw some money at this deal
and jacobi percent Mike
response this year yeah if Andrew Luck's
injuries are still thing you know who
else is a great former Tom Brady backup
Kliff Kingsbury he got a great job he
did try Ithaca thought a quarterback
come back with you back former backups
Matt Cassel Matt Cassel well you got a
lot of money for like four game Michael
Bishop played in NFL Europe Michael
Bishop never lose to come in at the end
of the first half and throw 60 yard Hail
Marys cuz Tom Brady didn't have the arm
for it although there's so many guys
Ryan boy I got that one that was me yeah
though you get that do you have to
another bat Kevin O'Connell
O'Connell or O'Connor one of them's a
reporter one of those I they drafted
from the LSU back in the day Rohan Davey
Riley
Rohan bacon counted in the Ryan Mallett
do we know they picked him up from
Arkansas he was like I love that Ryan
Mallett was like the guy that Brady felt
a little bit a little into me but it's
the Michael Vick thing we always get
back to it's like no one wants their
backup to be like coming at you a little
too athletic cuz they do really don't do
veterans it's like the three-year rookie
thing you have an O'Connell I guess is
now a coach in the league
hello I see somewhere yes you already
said that I I mentioned him yet yeah
okay then you win okay I have another
way for you this is this makes me feel
so great this tweet is from Matt
Lombardo there's a young Giants fan in
attendance at training camp can't be
older than 12 went up to Daniel Jones
and saved quote daniel Jones you
shouldn't have been the number six draft
pick and you didn't deserve so we always
like talk about like that's gross who
has best burns sometimes like the
simplest thing is is just the cheapest
we forgot one backup quarterback for Tom
Brady we forgot Drew Bledsoe as a backup
for Tom Brady yes I just I needed to say
that but just go ahead please no I just
daniel Jones in this preseason game on
Thursday night I already went through
the schedules this is how I'm gonna
watch Thursday Night Football I'm gonna
try and watch the Eagles and stream that
they're behind the Titans at 7:30 but
the national game jets-giants is the
national game at 7:00 on NFL Network and
then Chargers Cardinals at 10:00 so
really what I get to do is
watch Daniel Jones and then I'm gonna
watch Cuyler Marie nice so I think those
are both very good picks for the NFL
Network and then Friday I'm gonna wake
up very early and watch as much as I can
of all the other games mhm
just to see who's starting and preseason
football every year I get done and I go
that was a waste of my [ __ ] time but
I'm just so excited football's back but
that game it's seven o'clock
Eli might not play it's the it's the
primetime NFL game and Daniel Jones is
gonna be out there yeah he wants to get
a bar is so low for him man he needs to
throw a couple of Dimes the Gila throws
like I remember say qalam Barkley
against the Lions and their first
preseason game broke one out like for
like 30 yards and they pulled him that's
the dream scenario right as Daniel Jones
goes out there execute to drive there
was a 25-yard post to Evan Engram and
they have a handshake by the way very
important for me I see two guys go up
and they're like pop pop pop I'm like
the chemistry is brewing right because
you know Evan Engram wouldn't hi exactly
wouldn't have spent the time to come up
with a handshake if he didn't think it
was an investment worth making yes
like even Carson wenches corny-ass would
go up to wide receivers and they'd they
he had the one where he'd shake his hand
and then fix his tie and I was like no
like Carson is so good that they have to
have a hinge right and daniel Jones has
handshakes with nobody on the team I'm
very willing about that like him and Eli
are like like that weird thing we're
like one of them grabs a thumb back one
of them goes for the fist pound of the
other way and they do the thing that I
call the socket the socket it's just
like just looks like a shoulder bone
yeah yeah but so excited to see Daniel
Jones just looking through the other
preseason games obviously the Browns but
I don't think we're gonna see any of the
big-name guys really it's the rookies
that we care about yeah so like if we
see Marc if we see Hollywood Brown for
the Ravens I'd love that do we get a
series of Nick Foles for the Jaguars
Ismail Sanders the real deal for the
Eagles is Jared Stidham really turning
heads for the Patriots and then I just
want to see calimary
like I am over the moon excited for
calimary and talk about a guy that we're
where we as Twitterverse are so excited
for that first play where he breaks one
around the side or he he Jukes somebody
in the backfield and gets an 11 extra
yards yes that we are so dying for that
first play where we're like see that is
speed right there and it's gonna destroy
the NFL the other thing that I always
say is I want to make sure that the guy
is in the draft process that everybody
told me were big still look big so who's
the game Metcalfe or somebody like TK
Metcalfe I want to see like he we've
been talk about him being huge the whole
time when he's in a jersey and he's on
an NFL field does he land he looks
across at Chris Harris jr. or the
Broncos I need him to look the part
right because if all of a sudden he
doesn't look that big that was a whole
narrative the was it the defensive
lineman for the Giants
no Dexter Lawrence texture Lawrence
Mackay was a monster i but I want him to
go on the field be like who the hell is
that and because sometimes we bill up
these guys like in my head TJ Hawkinson
the tight end for the Lions was called
baby Gronk
okay well then when I turn on the game I
want him to look a little bit like Gronk
yeah but if he fits in like if I'm like
oh he just looks like a normal tight end
I lose a lot of my excitement I I mean
Tyler I need him to escape the pocket
and I need people to look like they're
in slow motion right like even if it's
just he's where he scrambles out of
bounds
I need a defensive end to do that thing
where they're like in a circle like
Pauling at air like I need to see that
just once a glimmer of do you member
that Carson Wentz highlight from a
couple years ago where he was just being
tackled by six guys who would somehow
just magically my first gif of all times
gonna say I'm sure you guys yeah I I
want one of those from Kyler where he
just emerges like Danny Woodhead yes
pile of cinnamon guys
yeah then he's just out it's like dude
Kyler Murray these gonna do some special
stuff I that to me first week preseason
game is just like give me football like
I need it right now yeah okay so my last
woe is apparently the culture and
Cleveland is so different that the leaks
have been plugged I love this quote from
Freddie kitchens I didn't realize this
I admit this guy's at Gelb at a
broadcasting seminar and then he had me
on his radio show well he had Bob Wiley
on his radio show Bob Wiley was the
offensive line for the Browns that
became a Hard Knocks legend last year
because yeah and his whole belly would
move Bob Wiley went on his radio show
and pretty much said Freddy kitchens was
not the reason that offense exploded
last year it was a quarterbacks coach
ken zambezi and we all feel left out
because Freddy kitchens got the job and
then said peace to all of us mmm
Freddy kitchens had energy at the press
conference when he was asked about it
where he said ask Bob who visit him in
the hospital every week as Bob Bob
wasn't under contract like he just aired
out all the truth about Bob Wiley then
it sounded like Bob Wiley was just a
friend of the organization and kept them
around and then soon after that he
addressed the leaks and he said this was
such vitriol in his eyes that I got so
excited for the future of the Browns he
said the days of insight information the
days of unnamed sources and stuff like
that have ended so you're not going to
get any information like that ever
anybody and if I ever see it they're
fired immediately that's the way we're
running this organization and I can take
it John Dorsey can take it
we won't crack I promise you I want to
say that one the beat reporter in
Cleveland Mary Kate Cabot is one of the
best reporters that this league has I've
done so many videos with her over the
year it's crazy but the reason she's
such a good reporter is she's been
around that organization right and
there's been so much carryover that
she's got a lot of sources so probably
the reason Freddy kitchens got rid of
all these old standbys is everybody is
like and we've all all work two jobs I
just which this company was how it was
before and I'm gonna say something like
they find ways to do that stuff and
Freddy kitchens cleaning out all of the
rats and telling the media pretty much
if you guys report something that comes
from a source I'm just letting you know
that if I find out who it was I'm gonna
fire them you know weird way it puts a
lot of pressure on the media too well
protecting your sources like ultra ultra
the shore is you don't want to lose that
sore but it also makes you go I'm not
reporting a source I'm not doing a story
with a source unless it's meaningful
[ __ ] right
like meaningful is it really worth it to
say who the nickle corner might be or if
it's a Antonio Callaway or Higgins
battling it out for the third wide
receiver you know might not be worth it
you know where I can see this heading is
let's say Mary Kay Cabot or some other
Cleveland shoutout let's say like let's
say one of these reporters they hear
something from a quote anonymous source
and they don't report it but they
utilize it in future reporting right I
could see this happening where now this
reporter has it comes armed with this
this nugget of information and they ask
Freddie kitchens about something that
they shouldn't know about and then
Freddie kitchen looks at them and he
says who told you that
who gave you that and then we're gonna
have that amazing yeah fascinating but
couldn't you see that happening in the
reason that it really resonated with me
is Freddie kitchens has been painted as
this Alabama happy-go-lucky and I can't
believe I have a head coaching job and
the number one question that I get asked
on radio shows is is this opportunity
too big for him and to see Freddie
kitchens turn into ball coach and say
this is my organization I hadn't seen
that yet I've only heard I like Baker
he's a lot of good time Modell's great
having have him back but for him to go
this is not the same Browns because my
issue with the Browns is their owner
their owner thinks that he can do
whatever he wants and it's his little
playpen and he doesn't know what he's
doing his his company had a 93 million
dollar bankruptcy case so I I'm still
question a lot of things about old
Haslam but I look at Freddie kitchens
and as I do more and more research to
make my picks in the next two weeks and
then as we go to Vegas I'm gonna put my
real money on these picks too
I'm getting more and more confident
about the Browns and it scares me to
death because it's it's betting on the
Browns to win the division is the
equivalent of saying this is the year
the Patriots and Tom Brady fall off mmm
every year you're gonna look dumb but I
really think this is the year for the
Browns they got a high-powered offense
and yeah there's Howard refresh legs
Kareem joining the team for the second
half second half energy boost all that
plus miles Aaron Ben loses Antonio Brown
and Le'Veon Bell like it seems like it
just seems like it's up for grabs
yeah I want to end on this though we
talked a lot about on money and
contracts the NFL and we always talk to
about reporters and who reports the news
again I'm not insulting anybody when if
I was a reporter and the Cowboys came to
me and said we've made very generous
offers to Zeke Amari and DAC all top
five I'm gonna report that so I'm never
blaming the reporter Jayne Slater NFL
Network is beloved by the Cowboys
organization she's always going live she
goes live from there during draft day
which means the team is they can be
selective - they could be like I don't
want that person you know in the NFL
never gonna go sorry but it might not
work out but she reported this and the
Jones family will not shut up and
they're really only gonna hurt
themselves in these negotiations they
came out and released this story early
in the day that they had given generous
offers okay that is state news one when
you tell me you've given to a top five
offer is that top five overall is that
top fried guaranteed money I don't care
about overall we've seen a lot of these
guys so they get like a hundred million
dollar deal with twenty guaranteed is we
care about top five guaranteed it came
out from Joe Xena
Anderson later in the day as we've noted
in this podcast the players reporter
which means it came from Zeke in Cabo
that Zeke is more than willing to whisk
games this year then Stephen Jones went
on a radio show later in the day why are
you doing a radio show you're a
businessman stop giving away information
if I was negotiating with Bleacher
Report and Bleacher board did a radio
show or they said well you know Dan
Patrick's paid this much but we
he's more of a Knick right like I'd be
like why are you telling people this
like you guys are saying it's just you
and me talking here and you care about
me but like you keep exposing me so here
the Cowboys are going out and he says we
think it's more levy on Melvin girlie
aka we think he's more 13 million
dollars a year than 14 million dollars a
year
Zeke does not have the injury history of
curly he is not coming off a year of not
playing football by levy on bail and
he's won the rushing title two of three
years and then Zeke comes out at nine
o'clock at night and there's a video
first video I've seen of him in Cabo in
a four-wheeler just driving by people go
Zeke and he just keeps going and that's
where Zeke's mindset is I don't care I I
firmly believe that Zeke is going to
miss games this year and the only way
it's gonna turn around isn't the Cowboys
lose games they play the Giants first
game of the year what I love about that
is that means they're gonna look across
the sidelines and see a top five running
back in sake one and they're gonna see
how much the Giants lean on him and then
they're gonna look at their own running
backs and go man
this would be really great if we had our
guy yeah I think Zeke's gonna miss games
I believe that Melvin Gordon's gonna
miss the entire year
I'm just letting everyone know I'm not
drafting either of those guys in fantasy
but I think the Zeke thing is gonna get
really ugly because I think what's gonna
happen is Jerry as I've said before is
gonna throw his support back in
Elliott's face I fought for you with
your domestic violence I fought for you
with your indecent exposure I fought for
you for this you owe me something and
Zeke's gonna go you told me that I
didn't do anything wrong you told me
that I was the victim because that's
what Jerry Jones said in the public and
now Jerry's trying to use it to his
advantage and Zeke is not one of those
guys that I think is gonna go you're
right Zeke is in another country he's
creating separation yeah and I think
it's gonna be separation that goes into
the season which I think will be very
interesting and it'll be overblown
because nothing gets talked about more
than the Dallas Cowboy
in this country oh yeah I could see it
being I mean leading the the front page
of every major sports site for 12
straight weeks Zeke Zeke update Zeke
watch yeah are you going to watch any of
the Patriots Lions game Thursday night
at 7:30 it'll probably have it on but I
just don't enjoy watching preseason
football cuz the Patriots will go in for
and people say is there something wrong
with Brady it's like no it doesn't
you're probably gonna have to stream it
illegally on Reddit so I don't know if
you're gonna be able to watch it in
cable
oh you're sayin yeah what I'll do is
I'll have my dad watch it just set up
his phone and I'll FaceTime his phone I
can watch but I would love you know what
this is what we're gonna do yeah if it
just hit me if you have a ps4 and you
don't have Madden yet I have a code but
here's the deal I'm not I'm just letting
everybody know I'm not being this guy
that's just like throwing codes on the
internet and like getting bagged all the
time if you send me your the setup that
you have for a preseason football game
on Thursday night like this and you
tweet at me and it's you're just
tweeting at me how you're watching
watching preseason football I will put
you in the running to win a Madden code
for ps4 about your battle station like
where yeah what is it yeah and the more
elaborate you get the better chance you
have to win I like this like if someone
somehow has seven preseason games up
like bro you've heard so if that guy
though exists and doesn't already have
Madden though like what are we dealing
with but guys I want you to enjoy your
weekend I want you to enjoy all of the
games we're gonna be coming back Monday
and it's gonna be I'm getting into my
battle station right now a lot of news a
lot of notes and I'm gonna try and
synthesize it in a way in which it
explains future abetting betting overs
and unders and the injuries and the
moves I think will impact the season
because I'm gonna that this weekend's
work and I'm [ __ ] excited
so for ingmar love co the lef koe man
Vince Carter congratulation
on everything welcome back to the
Atlanta Hawks I'll have fun kicking it
with your teammates dad and that's it
you got to say if you're making your
scrambled eggs in under five minutes
your flame is up too high it should be a
low and slow process really good advice
yet again peace out guys hallo hallo